accusé de fraude fiscale le président de
la république italienne giovanna léonais
démissionne raymond barre à genève pour
une économie créatrice d'emplois contre
l'illusion d'une politique volontariste
la défense à l'assemblée yvon bourges
pas de sixième sous-marin nucléaire
mais une nouvelle génération aux
performances accrues le président
giscard d'estaing le financement des
partis politiques
une pratique déjà connus à l'étranger
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir il y a trois minutes tout juste
nous apprenions la démission donc de
giovanni leone et c'est à dire le
président de la république italienne et
cela mérite bien sûr un long
développement en début de ce jour là il
y a deux jouent en effet un hebdomadaire
l'accusait de fraude fiscale et de
spéculation immobilière dans la foulée
la plupart des journaux italiens se sont
mis à réclamer sa démission les partis
politiques ont pris le relais en
demandant que la lumière soit faite et
tout à leur lit à deux trois heures à
peu près le parti communiste qui
jusqu'àlors soutenait le gouvernement à
réclamer à son tour la démission du chef
de l'état démission effective je voulais
dit depuis 30 minutes
alors avec nous en direct derrière moi
victor vraiment comment est ce qu'on a
pu arriver à cela et bien victor oui on
vous voir ne vous entend pas
malheureusement pour l'instant nous
allons tout faire pour essayer de
rétablir cette liaison sont c'est
dommage nous avions la liaison images
avec rome dans quelques secondes je
pense que c'est une affaire de seconde
nous aurons aussi l'extrait de la
déclaration télévisée de giovanni
lyonnais qui a donc à 19h55 a annoncé
aux téléspectateurs italiens qu'il
démissionnait à la suite de cette
affaire de pots-de-vin et de cette
affaire de corruption et de spéculation
immobilière voici lier cet extrait la
télévision italienne
voilà ça c'est ce que la télévision
italienne diffusée quelques minutes
avant que giuly nenê ne prenne la parole
et vous avez reconnu des pancartes
demandant la démission du président
léonais car il avait déjà été accusé de
fraude dans la sphère loup qui il avait
été accusé de recevoir des pots de vin
de la part des américains
il faut rappeler qui est du riz ni les
années maintenant rappeler aussi que ce
n'est pas la première fois donc on
l'accuse de corruption
ainsi donc ce sujet sur giovanni n'est
accusé de corruption interne lockheed
c'était devenu leone et du temps de sa
splendeur le jour de la fête nationale
en 77
le président italien était déjà accusé
d'avoir touché des pots-de-vin de la
société aéronautique américaine lockheed
pour arrondir ses fins de mois
mais la presse italienne n'avait pu
établir les preuves formelles
giovanni leone et avait même réussi à
faire condamner le journal l'espresso
pour outrage à chef de l'état mais
pendant ce temps monsieur leone et
s'offrait sa villa de 39 pièce au bord
de la mer en mars dernier sénateurs et
députés avaient failli faire passer
giovanni leone et devant la cour
constitutionnelle pour avoir reçu des
pots-de-vin de lalo ty
mais finalement ce sont deux anciens
ministres de la défense luigi et mario
tama ci qui avait écopé giovanni leone
et avait été sauvée par sa fonction
essentiellement honorifique mais ce soir
tous les députés italiens savent qu'ils
devront voter
six mois avant la fin du mandat
présidentiel pour un nouveau chef de
l'état voilà on me dit que la liaison
sont avec victor amant n'est
malheureusement toujours pas rétabli en
revanche je crois que nous sommes dans
la capacité de vous montrer l'extrême de
la télévision italienne il ya quelques
minutes à peine
un commentateur de la télévision
italienne explique en ce moment que les
députés devront revoter six mois avant
la fin du mandat présidentiel qui se
termine en effet en glissant un mandat
purement honorifique et qui se terminait
donc en décembre après sept années de
pouvoir par monsieur giovanni leonetti
c'est une annonce qui existent aussi ati
vient italienne puisque vous savez qu'on
peut recevoir antenne 2 et en soirée
d'information en français alors je vais
essayer une nouvelle tentative avec
victor vraiment victor est ce que vous
m'entendez cette fois ci moi je vous en
aviez failli et oumarou vient alors
comment est ce qu'on a pu arriver donc à
cette démission du chef de l'état
italien
eh bien écoutez tout d'abord le
président giovanni leone est tout
simplement accusé de fraude fraude
fiscale effectivement il ya quelques
années le président leur nez avait
acheté un terrain près de rome et il
avait profité d'exemptions fiscales dans
la mesure où ils s'engager à construire
sur ce terrain des logements populaires
voilà que par la suite on apprend que le
président leone et s'est fait construire
tout simplement une superbe villa de 39
chambres et puis ce n'est pas tout
puisque l'hebdomadaire l'espresso accuse
le président de la république de s'être
fait construire cette superbe villa
grâce à des pots-de-vin de la lockheed
alors bon c'est une vieille histoire
mais voilà que cet après-midi le parti
communiste italien demande
officiellement la démission du président
de la république et ça c'est pas
l'important oui puisque à partir du
moment où le parti communiste italien
qui fait partie de la majorité actuelle
demande la démission du président c'est
donc que les jeux sont faits cela dit
jusqu'à maintenant c'était plutôt les
radicaux le petit parti radical qui a
quatre députés au parlement
c'était donc les radicaux qui étaient
les plus virulents
la députée radicale emma bonino avait
même dénoncé pour fraude fiscale le
président de la république auprès du
procureur de la république
voilà donc un nouveau scandale très
grave qui secoue l'italie pourquoi très
grave
et bien tout simplement parce que cette
fois cela concerne tout de même le
premier personnage de la république
italienne
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer
maintenant victor vraiment car l'italie
est vraiment en crise en ce moment on
avait dit à un moment qu'elle domoraud
aurait pu succéder à giovanni leone est
venue de son sort bien entendu oui la
question ne se pose donc plus l on peut
faire des projections sur l'avenir
oui ce qui va se passer c'est d'après la
constitution c'est donc le président du
sénat à minto les fans fagnes qui va
occuper les fonctions de président de la
république par intérim
cela dit maintenant il reste sept mois
avant l'élection du nouveau président de
la république qui aura lieu en décembre
bon cela dit rien pardon valence et 7
mois insee passa rien non il ne peut
rien se passer d'ailleurs pendant les
six premiers mois qui précèdent une
élection présidentielle il ne peut rien
se passer d'elle ne peut pas y avoir ni
d'élections ni de crise politique
c'est en tout cas ce que prévoit la
constitution et il semble qu'aucun parti
politique surtout pas les communistes ne
veulent profiter de la situation enfin
l'exploiter je pense que seuls les
radicaux qui comme je voulais tu y es tu
un tout petit parti essaiera de profiter
à fond de cette situation de se braquer
une fois encore contre le régime
mais je pense que les partis qui
constituent la majorité actuelle seront
d'un calme exemplaire
voilà donc ce que nous pouvions dire à
chaud sur ce dossier italien puisque je
vous le rappelle encore une l'avons
appris qu'il y a dix minutes durée ni
leone et le président de la république
italienne a été obligé de démissionner
figurez-vous que l'un de nos autres
voisins la belgique est également en
crise depuis cet après midi puisque
monsieur et ils demandent ce que vous
voyez ici
reçus kingdom ans annonce qu'en ce
moment même sa démission du gouvernement
belge pour une affaire de budget et de
discussions au sein de la coalition
gouvernementale qui effectivement est
une gouvernement un cabinet de coalition
entre différents partis voilà deuxième
page de ce journal un petit peu moins
précipitée que la première et j'espère
que vous nous excuser pour les
applications techniques car nous avons
vécu l'actualité en direct la deuxième
page de ce journal ce sont les problèmes
sociaux avec toujours le statu quo chez
renault rno qui menace de fermer l'usiné
de flins si la grève à l'atelier dé
presse poursuit avec aussi un mouvement
de grève qui s'étend dans les arsenaux
force ouvrière a décidé l'extension de
ce mouvement tout en restant opposée à
l'occupation de ses locaux
c'est un dossier que nous avons commencé
à aborder hier et que nous reprendrons
profondeur car il n'est pas sans
conséquence avec enfin les propos de
raymond barre qui tout à l'heure à
genève s'exprimer devant la 64e
conférence internationale du travail et
mon beurre devant le bureau
international du travail s'est un petit
peu la concrétisation de ce que disait
valéry giscard d'estaing hier dans sa
conférence de presse
en effet la france fait entendre sa voir
dans une organisation internationale
pourtant le bt est un morceau du machin
selon les termes général de gaulle il
fait partie de l'eau est nu un machin
l'on envisage l'avenir avec une certaine
angoisse les chiffres du chômage ne
cessera d'augmenter cela d'ailleurs été
l'un des thèmes de raymond barre qui a
expliqué devant quelques 140 pays quelle
était la politique de la france en
matière d'emploi une vraie politique de
l'emploi est d'abord une politique
économique permettant aux entreprises de
produire dans des conditions saines pour
répondre à la demande intérieure et à la
demande internationale
c'est également une série d'actions
sectorielles coordonnées permettant
d'améliorer le fonctionnement du marché
de l'emploi telle est la conception de
la politique spécifique que conduit le
gouvernement français en matière
d'emploi elle s'oriente autour de trois
axes développer la formation de base et
la qualification des hommes
en second lieu
améliorer les conditions de travail par
l'aménagement des postes de travail mais
également par une revalorisation
systématique de la condition matérielle
et psychologique des travailleurs
manuels en dernier lieu poursuivre une
politique vigoureuse d'aménagement du
territoire
car la france qui a fait un effort
important dans ce domaine continue à
être un pays où coexistent des vrais des
régions industrialisées ou les
entreprises n'arrivent pas à trouver de
la main d'oeuvre et des zones qui
connaissent un grave chômage je te
qu'une quinzaine de délégués arabes et
africains ont quitté la salle pour
protester contre la politique africaine
de la france précisé si cette conférence
avait un certain panache et qu on y
célébrait le centième anniversaire de la
naissance d'albert thomas un ministre
socialiste français qui fut le premier
directeur du bureau international du
travail aujourd'hui c'est encore un
français francis blanchard qui est à la
tête du pays tu es le btk pour nous
radio scoop et la nièvre en clinique
le principe du bureau international du
travail est née de la première guerre
mondiale
des ouvriers de 1917 ne voulait plus se
battre et mourir pour une vie sans
véritable espoir de bonheur alors pour
que les usines de canne on ne s'arrête
pas albert thomas ministre de l'armement
a lancé une idée révolutionnaire qui
s'est concrétisée à la signature du
traité de versailles en 1919 une
organisation été créée à genève
elle devait réunir travailleurs patrons
et représentants de tous les
gouvernements des pays du monde
aujourd'hui 136 pays sont membres du b
it et les conditions de travail sont
améliorées mais l'horizon est toujours
fonds en l'an 2000 selon les experts de
l'organisation
il y aura environ un milliard cent
cinquante millions de chômeurs la
priorité des priorités c'est donc
désormais l'emploi 700 experts sont
présents dans 115 pays pour enseigner ce
b habana sur rue depuis la signature de
la première convention sur la durée du
travail c'était à washington en 1919
jusqu'à la 146e sur la pollution le bt a
établi un code international du travail
très complet mais les conventions comme
les traités doivent être ratifiés par
les parlements de chaque état pour être
appliqué en fait depuis quelques années
les états aux revenus sont en avance sur
la plupart des conventions adoptées à
genève reste le problème des pays en
voie de développement
il est lourd grave échange le
fonctionnement d'organisation était très
utile dans le passé il peut encore avoir
un très grand rôle celui qui
consisterait à éviter que la concurrence
internationale se fasse à partir des
politiques sociales car trop souvent la
concurrence internationale se fait à
partir de conditions inégales des
travailleurs mais il ya une condition à
cela c'est que le bit et travaille
vraiment sur les problèmes sociaux ne
soit pas bloquée par les problèmes
politiques les représentants de ces pays
en voie de développement viennent pour
discuter ces problèmes sociaux c'est
incontestable mais
viennent aussi pour utiliser les
tribunes qui leur sont offertes et sa
des conséquences notamment le départ des
etats-unis d'amérique conséquences
graves y compris pour les clips et le
financement de l'institution donc des
problèmes politiques
il ne reste pas moins qu'après cinquante
neuf années le b iter est la seule
organisation internationale ou patrons
ouvriers et gouvernants parle d'
ensemble dans la soirée raymond barre
invité d'honneur de l'oit et devait
regagner paris pour assister à la fin du
débat sur la défense à l'assemblée débat
dont nous rendrons compte dans quelques
minutes
raymond barre qui a bénéficié hier d'un
satisfecit remarquée de la part du
ponant république dans sa conférence de
presse de cette réunion d'hier après
midi nous vous avons tous dit nous avons
donné également l'essentiel des
réactions je vois quand même ajouter le
jugement du rpr ce matin par la voix de
son secrétaire général alain devaquet
qui estime que pour la première fois le
président la république a eu une vision
à long terme de la france
aujourd'hui nous avons choisi
d'approfondir une proposition du
président qui fera couler beaucoup
d'encre car beaucoup de gouvernements
s'y sont ouvertes et sans succès une
certaine moralisation de la vie
politique française à travers le
financement des partis déjà il ya quatre
ans le président giscard d'estaing avait
souhaité qu'un pas soient faits pour
assainir un dossier jusqu alors trop
secret un dossier qui était laissée à la
discrétion des uns et des autres le
président de la république par les tiers
du caractère clandestin du financement
des partis politiques
c'est vrai les recettes traditionnelles
constitué par les cotisations des
souscriptions les salaires des élus ne
constitue qu'une partie ou même un
trompe l'oeil des revenus des formations
politiques
le reste provient de sources officieuses
puiser dans des fous dit secret la
politique ça coûte cher très cher et la
part du financement occulte et donc de
plus en plus grande
alors si l'on veut libérer la politique
de l'argent il faut donner de l'argent à
la politique
il s'agit je crois de favoriser un
meilleur exercice de la démocratie de
donner une plus grande dignité à la
politique et surtout à l'occasion de
l'élection européenne de mettre les
partis politiques français dans une
situation d'égalité de chances avec les
autres partis politiques européens qui
eux bénéficient d'une aide publique et
d'un certain plafonnement des dépenses
c'est pourquoi le point sur lequel je
suis pas d'accord avec le président de
la république sait qui prévoit
l'application de cette mesure à partir
de 1980 alors que nous avons une
élections européennes en 1979 alors
j'espère que cette proposition de loi
pourra être voté lors de la prochaine
session parlementaire
je crois que c'est très important pour
la démocratie vie insiste car les
français savent qu'on dépense beaucoup
d'argent beaucoup trop d'argent pour les
campagnes électorales et que précisément
raison de cette aide est quelquefois un
pur qu'il reçoit du secteur privé est
bien les partis politiques ne sont pas
suffisamment libre
les radicaux de gauche déposeront
précisément une proposition de loi sur
le financement des partis avant le 30
juin
dans l'ensemble tous les partis ont bien
accueilli aujourd'hui la proposition du
chef de l'état
seul le parti communiste s'élèvent
contre ce qu'ils appellent une ingérence
de l'état dans la conduite des partis le
parti socialiste et le ps eut font une
mise en garde à propos du système de la
répartition de l'argent
le président a parlé d'une somme
proportionnelle au nombre des nues or ce
mode de versement peut défavoriser les
petites formations
le ps eu par exemple n'a pas de député
pour la majorité le rpr juge que cette
proposition est une bonne suggestion
le parti républicain la preuve
allemand le cds lui demande une
limitation des dépenses faites au cours
des campagnes
car si l'on veut que l'aide de l'état
établissent une réelle égalité des
chances
il faut l'accompagner d'un contrôle ou
même d'une interdiction des ressources
extérieures
ce qui paraît impossible en france et
qui en tout cas elle n'a jamais encore
été réalisées pourtant une affaire
parfaitement maîtrisé par plusieurs des
grandes démocraties
il y à l'exemple italien tout neuf
puisque approuvée par référendum
dimanche dernier il ya aussi
l'expérience des allemands des anglais
est d'abord des amériques aux états unis
où le financement des campagnes et
privés l'élection d'un président coûte
en moyenne 15 milliards de centimes par
candidat cette somme représente le
plafond autorisé par la loi américaine
les deux grands partis républicains et
démocrates sont assez inégalement
financer et la préférence des financeurs
les grosses sociétés va le plus souvent
au république mais ses concours
financiers sont rarement des intéressés
les donneurs considèrent leur argent non
seulement comme contribution mais aussi
comme un placement une assurance voire
une monnaie d'échangé à noter aussi aux
sénatoriales de 1970 sur quinze
candidats des plus grands et à 11
étaient des milliardaires les quatre
qu'il n'était pas ont été battus en
allemagne fédérale le système est
différent la loi oblige les parties à
présenter chaque année une comptabilité
détaillé qui indique l'origine de leurs
ressources financières
mais surtout c'est l'état qui finance
les campagnes électorales lors d'une
consultation chaque électeur inscrit
donne environ 5 francs au fisc
l'argent est ensuite redistribué aux
partis en fonction des suffrages obtenus
au bundestag
en italie c'est également le
contribuable qui finance les parties ce
système restaurer mais 74 à présent gros
scandale où étaient impliqués des
compagnies pétrolières
vers qui finançait des candy en italie
donc tous les ans l'état distribue
environ 23 milliards de centimes aux
partis politiques
et cet argent est répartie en fonction
de la représentation au par le change de
quoi les partis sont obligés de déposer
rendre public chaque année un bilan
financier
mais ce système n'a pas supprimé les
financements occultes les parties au
plus d'argent chaque année un point
c'est tout et selon un récent référendum
un électeur italien sur deux et pour la
suppression de cette subvention
c'est dire le bien que pense le voisin
italien du financement électoral par
l'état vous voyez comment l actualité
c'est aujourd'hui pour une affaire
financière précisément que tombent
aujourd'hui le président léonais en
bresse maintenant toujours en france
annulation d'une seconde élections
législatives après celle de marie
thérèse guthmann en seine-saint-denis le
conseil cautionnait la décidé d'annuler
celle de monsieur andres l'art député
socialiste du cher un nouveau pdg pour
l' agence havas yves cannac jusqu alors
secrétaire général adjoint de l'elysée
remplace jean méhault james marange est
nommé conseiller d'état ainsi en a
décidé le conseil des ministres monsieur
marc angers a été longtemps secrétaire
général de la fgts haine et le mois
dernier gérard jacquet ancien ministre
socialiste avait lui aussi été nommé
conseiller d'état la justice dans la
société française ce sera le thème d'une
journée d'étude de l'udf le 22 juin et
c'est son délégué général michel
printemps qui l'a confirmé aujourd'hui
au parlement la commission neuwirth se
déclare en faveur des concours de
pronostics nous entendrons le député
lucien neuwirth exprimé là dessus dans
notre dernier journal nous entendrons
aussi christian bilhac le ministre de
l'éducation qui une fois de plus a
répété qu'il n'y aurait pas de réformes
berck vote de la loi sur les plus values
ce matin à l'aube il n'a manqué à la
majorité qu'une dizaine de voix
gaullistes on celle de edgar faure et de
pierre messmer et quelques heures plus
tard les députés ont enchaîné avec un
débat sur la défense mais warrants de
voir le compte rendu leurs travaux et
daniel brême propose d'examiner le fond
du dossier les besoins des milieux
en grande partie la politique de défense
de la france basée sur la force de
dissuasion les armements sont donc
essentiellement développée dans ce but
peut être au détriment d'armes plus
classique
d'autre part les accords de coopération
ou de défense que nous avons avec
certains pays étrangers ont fait que nos
forces sont intervenues loin de nos
frontières
cette politique de défense n'est pas
exempte de problèmes notamment dans le
transport des troupes dans l'armement
individuel et dans la marine dans le
domaine du transport le transall un
avion franco-allemand moyen courriers a
montré qu'il était inutilisable pour des
missions lointaines et rapide le
gouvernement n'envisage d'ailleurs pas
d'acheter de plus gros avions cependant
25 nouveaux transall plus puissants
viennent d'être commandés leur autonomie
devrait être de 7500 km au lieu de cinq
mille cinq cents
lors de l'intervention du zaïre les
parachutistes ont comparé leur armement
personnel avec celui des troupes qu'ils
affrontaient essentiellement du matériel
russe fusil-mitrailleur ak-47
l'état major a porté son choix pour
remplacer le lieu masse et la
mitraillette m 49 sur un fusil d'assaut
le famas qui a été surnommé le clairon
cette arme peut être utilisé comme fusil
comme mitraillette ou comme fusil
mitrailleur avec une puissance de feu
supérieure à tous ces contenus la mise
au point de cet engin qui sera en
service dans les unités au début de
l'année prochaine a été très longue
une raison à cela une mise au point
délicate pour en faire une arme
exceptionnel troisième problème la
marine fondée en partie sur cinq sous
marins nucléaires
certains experts de l'état majeure
estime qu'il faut en avoir trois en
réserve et 2 constamment en mer pour
garder une certaine efficacité
dissuasive
si l'un d'eux tombe en panne l'équilibré
rompu ici la raison pour laquelle ils en
réclament un sixième pour les autres
navires le tonnage ne cesse de diminuer
il sera de 320 milles tonnes environ
l'année prochaine deux porte avions un
porte-hélicoptères 23 sous marins
classiques de près gap
un croiseur et une centaine de navires
de petit tonnage la marine met en avant
les deux tâches qu'on lui impose la
défense et le service civil en
particulier la surveillance des couloirs
maritimes et avec l'augmentation des
eaux territoriales
les marins de la royale ont peur de ne
plus pouvoir assurer leur travail
elle vous le voyez ce fusil clair on est
là devant moi sa puissance est paraît-il
tout à fait remarquable elle vaut dix
fois celle d'une voiture du mans celle
d'une formule 1 et j'ai même les balles
les anciennes balles qui sont celles ci
beaucoup plus grande et les nouvelles
que vous voyez 5,56 voilà donc ce fusil
d'assaut masse 5,56 vulgairement appelée
donc le fusil clairon fabriqués dans la
manufacture d'armes de saint-etienne et
bien tout à l'heure à la tribune de
l'assemblée général bigeard a évoqué à
sa manière un petit peu gouailleuse
l'historique de la naissance du fusil
moderne qui dotera l'armée française à
l'étranger
ecoutez-le j'avais dit à l'époque il
faudrait comme acheter le fusil 5,56
américain qui a fait ses preuves en
indochine ennemis de la défense avait
dit à juste titre on ne peut pas il faut
que ce soit fabrication française
alors nous sommes allés là bas on a
remué les ingénieurs en disant faites
vite il tire il est pas mal on acide
excité mais voyez ça c'est pas si
facilement que ça il paraît qu'à une
balle qui est en acier
ça frotte un petit peu la chambre qui a
pris 2 un petit peu une marge supérieure
ce qui fait qu'un certain nombre de
coups ça s'arrose
alors ils vont faire une balle en plus
mais l'année prochaine je pense que nous
l'aurons donc c'est en cours et je pense
qu'il fallait quand même boire français
et je pense que la ministre avait raison
alors ça c'est pour l'anecdote renom
maintenant au débat proprement dit
ouvert par le ministre donc yvon bourges
qui a réaffirmé la continuité de la
politique de défense de la france fondée
en priorité sur la dissuasion nucléaire
puis ensuite daniel brême le
traditionnel défilé des orateurs à la
tribune
oui
le général bigeard le savez c'est un peu
le singe en bouche d'or du palais
bourbon
alors il a fait beaucoup de gestes
l'animé les paras en train de sauter ou
chabat et il a ajouté est-ce que les
crédits de la défense sont suffisants et
bien évidemment non mais on ne peut tout
de même pas demander aux français de
rouler en vélo et de ne ressembler leurs
chaussures que tous les trois mois
mais alors il faut être vigilant le
l'exposé de l'ex légionnaire messmer a
été beaucoup moins balancer il a salué
au passage avec fierté les paras et les
marsouins qui ont sauté à kolwezi
né il a également donné rendez-vous à
monsieur bourges sous forme d'ultimatum
si vous ne donnez pas ou rpr des
assurances sur la construction du
sixième sous-marin nucléaire à l'automne
est bien ne voteront pas votre budget
deuxième sommation répondait clairement
pour suivre et vous ou non les essais
nucléaires etc avis le ministre sur le
sixième sous-marin il en a pas encore
parlé
si mel a donné rendez vous à l'automne
79 ce qui ne rassure pas pour autant
évidemment le rp alors qu'est ce qui
s'est dit dans votre corps va bien dans
l'autre comme monsieur hernu pour les
socialistes
et monsieur dernier pour les communistes
ont exprimé une multitude de crainte
allez vous placez les missiles plutôt en
territoire allemand
ils ont crié danger réintégration
subreptice à l'ô tan désarmement poudre
aux yeux
vous avez semble-t-il intention de
supprimer le service national au profit
de l'armée de métier est en fait dernier
souhait de monsieur hernu il faut que
les commissions de la défense de
l'assemblée et du sénat puisse donner
leur avis sur toutes les ventes d'armes
à l'étranger une lettre du chef de
l'état son premier ministre après son
voyage en corse et lui définit une
nouvelle politique pour lille avec le
désir d'assurer au sein de la république
la pleine égalité des chances à la corse
et à ses habitants un nouveau président
pour le syndicat de la presse économique
juridique et de gestion monsieur bérard
quélin le pdg de la société générale de
presse journalistes depuis 40 ans et
puis à nouveau les halles il ya quelques
années
de l'état souhaitait un grand jardin
dans le trou des halles mais depuis on a
eu l'impression que le béton pousser
plus vite que les arbres et deux
conseillers de paris de socialistes s'en
sont émus à quoi ressemblera le jardin
des halles les derniers projets
présentés par l'architecte beaux filets
par la société d'aménagement des halles
avait séduit par leur classicisme mais
au fur et à mesure que les travaux
avancent et on s'est inquiété devant la
floraison de ces tourelles nécessaire à
l'aération et à la sécurité du sous sol
elles seront faciles à camoufler disait
lui-même l'architecte beau fils qui
puisait pour se faire dans les bonnes
vieilles recettes du xviiie siècle
seulement voilà on ne s'attendait pas à
un tel déploiement de béton il y à 32
tours au total au coeur même du futur
parc
il faut que les parisiens et les
français sachent que si des décisions
très courageux ne sont pas pris dans les
prochains jours au lieu et place du
jardin prévu c'est une sorte d'immense
shore de citernes dimanche champs de
béton que l'on contemple aura en effet
de toutes parts sur le plateau des
halles surgiront des excroissances des
protubérances certaines hautes de cinq
mètres qui obstruent rond la vision et
qui surtout en les virant le site
techniquement on peut trouver d'autres
solutions à condition d'agir vite
on a bien prévu par exemple de faire
disparaître cette énorme centrale
thermique derrière un immeuble
d'habitation mais les deux conseillers
socialistes de paris jacques lang et
georges dayan qui dénoncent ce qu'ils
appellent le massacre des halles ont un
autre sujet d'inquiétude
l'apparence architectural des trois
bâtiments en forme de u qui fermeront la
place trois architectes sont désignés
ils travaillent chacun de leur côté ils
ne se rencontrent jamais qu'en sera-t-il
alors de l'unité de style mieux vaudrait
confier l'ensemble un seul architecte
c'est une décision à prendre rapidement
disent les socialistes car les
bétonneuses elles n'attendent pas que
puisque nous parlons des problèmes
parisien il faut savoir que jacques
chirac a décidé de réunir les présidents
de groupes du conseil de paris demain
matin et que le problème des relations
entre la ville de paris et l'état sera
une fois de plus abordé le dossier se
présente mal une note d'espoir pour
terminer sachez que elisabeth hour
basher cette jeune femme handicapée qui
devait être saisie pour non-paiement de
contraventions aujourd'hui ne l'a pas
été sans doute lui sied la ville de
paris ont ils été sensible à ce portrait
que nous avions tracé dès la vente hier
et pour lequel vous avez été nombreux à
nous écrire
il nous faut maintenant faire le point
sur la sphère donc de la démission de
monsieur giovanni leone et le président
la république italienne avec noël mamère
une petite lecture très rapide que vous
avez fait de la constitution italienne
et qui nous permet de savoir quand et
bien les textes prévoient que dans un
délai de 15 jours pour la démission du
président de la république ont réuni les
représentants des deux chambres c'est à
dire les députés les sénateurs ainsi que
les représentants des régions pour
procéder à l'élection d'un nouveau
président de la république je vous avais
promis tout à l'heure en début de
journal
un extrait du bulletin spécial que la
télévision italienne a donc offert à ses
téléspectateurs qui est l' annonce en
direct donc de la démission de monsieur
leone et nous allons pouvoir maintenant
à suivre le président leone et a déclaré
qu'il démissionnait dans l'intérêt du
pays
parce qu'il voulait mettre fin aux
bruits aux rumeurs couraient à son sujet
il expliqué sa décision par les attaques
des journalistes et de la presse en
général je regrette de devoir laisser
cette tâche a déclaré monsieur leone et
qui a fait ensuite un bilan de ses
activités politiques
et pour terminer son allocution il a
ajouté non sans amertume
je vous souhaite progrès et justice dans
ce pays
avant de nous quitter sachez d'abord
qu'il y avait un tiercé cet après-midi
la combinaison gagnante est la suivante
le 8 le 7 et le 4 le rapport dans
l'ordre pour 5 francs est le suivant que
vous pouvez découvrir sur votre écran un
petit peu plus de 7000 francs et dans un
ordre différent un peu plus de 15 et 100
francs voilà ce stade du journal et
c'est vraiment la fin nous voudrions
élevé une protestation qui a très peu de
chances d'être entendus car je ne sais
pas trop comment nous reçoit là haut je
veux parler du temps nous sommes très
précisément le 15 juin à six jours de
l'été et tout se détraque un mois de mai
pour y un début juin qui promet mais
depuis une semaine des températures
anormalement basses alors aujourd'hui
encore de la pluie sur la région
parisienne
des orages dans le sud et en montagne
bref ça ne va pas et on a envie de
savoir ce que nous réserve le week-end à
venir alors d'abord le constat laurent
broomhead et bien effectivement il ya
une période de boutons nacrés cité le
mois d'août est malheureusement comme
c'est normal au mois de juin
il ya du mauvais temps une zone de
mauvais temps qui s'est déclenché au
nord de l'islande et qui tranquillement
des soins il va passer au nord de la
france pendant le week-end elle va mener
des perturbations successives en flot
continu alors concrètement qu'est ce que
ça veut dire pour demain alors demain
vendredi
demain la première vague c'est le
carrosse paris en ce moment elle va être
sur l'est depuis le jura le jura jusqu'à
l'alsace derrière mais y aura des
éclaircies belle normal
et puis derrière malheureusement ça
c'est ennuyeux il va y avoir une poussée
d'une deuxième vague de mauvais temps
beaucoup plus virulente et dans toute la
journée elle va envahir toute la france
attention ravale de vente pour les
plaisanciers dans le golfe de gascogne
ça signifie pour ceux qui partent en
week-end les biens la fois il faut
prendre part à puis il faut prendre les
imperméables et le samedi sera pas très
bon et nous ont alors le samedi ça va
guère plus gai le temps sera frais sur
toute la france les températures vont
encore baisser
il y aura des averses des orages sur à
peu près toute la france tout de même
une petite note d'optimiste sur le sud
sur la moitié sud quelques belles
éclaircies
en conclusion on peut espérer pour
dimanche on peut espérer que les
éclaircies l'emporteront sur le mauvais
temps enfin tout état de cause être
mosquée al azhar révélé un week-end
vraiment maussade gars n'avaient pas
intérêt à vous trompez car à partir
d'aujourd'hui vous êtes notre messieurs
29 monsieur météo de cours donc décidé
de mettre davantage l'accent sur les
prévisions du temps et d'être si
possible meilleur que les autres
vous reviendrez nous voir donc avant
chaque week-end et puis à chaque fois
que l'actualité l'obligent et si
possible en totale jeudi soir voilà je
vous rappelle que notre bernier journal
vous sera présenté à 23 heures patrick
lecocq
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée
bonsoir à tous adeptes